I'll buy that for twenty to sixty
dollars what RoboCup I'll buy that for a
dollar
that's a deep cut there John it's a deep
cut so clever we're gonna watch the
Mortal Kombat aftermath and Robocop
reveal trailer all right let's just
swing into this our work is finished
okay
oh the doctor strange portals
they get the original actor to return
for the it looks just like give me I
then they get the voice nice Botto arms
where's my Robocop oh damn
one guys looks like the new look
next how they as a recovery actor
regular people okay
see that's where you should have said
you have the right to remain silent
Robocop kick an ass fatality son boy
it's been a very long time since I've
followed the actual storyline of Mortal
Kombat I mean I've pretty much picked up
every single game but I've only tested
out every single character playing with
friends and such but I like the concept
ended up itself having an additional
story line instead of who's making a
Mortal Kombat 12 you do this aftermath
extra story content I wish I could talk
more about that but I think the concept
of it is cool and maybe I'll just start
playing actual story modes again a long
time since I've seen a Mortal Kombat
trailer with a storyline in it and just
had a fighting game experience that had
an integral storyline that was not very
separate from the actual game you know
as I own 9 and 10 I haven't bought a
loving yet but I've pretty much played
as every character at my friend's house
but having Robocop in here I think is a
great addition DLC characters are these
add-ons I always get a little bit
trepidatious about because a lot of
times they sound great in concept and
then you actually use them and they're
not the best players to use like the
design and just having them there in
context is always a really neat thing
but it's it doesn't always make for the
most rewarding experience so but that
being said you know I'm gonna wait for
the gameplay trailer a Robocop to come
out and your best bet we're gonna be
reacting to that one because I mean
Robocop being an addition in here I
think is wonderful I feel like it would
be cool to just keep getting more of
these movie characters it's what they've
been doing you mean getting like a
Ripley from aliens show up here I think
would be really neat even going further
out might not be an 80s character for
getting like the bride from Kill Bill
like these are a lot of my like fan
fiction character concepts right now
Robocop feels more Intune with the other
DLC characters been added on but I think
also having Shiva return is a great
touch she did not get her do in Mortal
Kombat annihilation I remember playing
her in the very very early days of
Mortal Kombat man
oh gosh she was she's looks freaking
great here I'm not familiar with this
other character food food Jaden cooing I
don't remember that character but Shiba
I definitely know Robocop obviously now
we should get the Robocop rebooted
character here I'd be the next great
step in that actor who is being replaced
by other people and big franchises uh
yeah no I mean this looks really awesome
and I am curious about the longevity of
Mortal Kombat because obviously it's
been around for so long but it seems
like it has gone through these ups and
downs of right now it is experiencing a
tremendous up on the heels of nine ten
and now 11 and so partly I wonder if
maybe this is a good way to maintain
that longevity forward because you know
there are only so many ways you can
repackage a fighting Kombat game and so
having the draw of these characters and
maybe like you said expanding the range
of the characters to incorporate less
likely but equally badass characters and
maybe get that sort of fanfiction
element going be pretty nice because it
seems like they like to crank these
characters out and sort of keep the
games alive that way which is really
smart I don't know what the rights
issues are a copyright infringement new
things are when it comes to obtaining
these characters before my look into
because I feel like that make it easier
to narrow it down but the feather you
die like the t800 now and Robocop
you had a real chance to go toe-to-toe
in that fun department they've already
got a bunch of the horror characters in
there I think anything like Freddy
Krueger I don't know if they're gonna
play they've gone for a burger before
but I think getting pretty crude or
after you have Jason Voorhees and
Leatherface them all that that'd be
really cool I'm also kind of curious
because Mortal Kombat seems to be
leaning more into its storytelling
departments they got the scorpion movie
that's out that a lot of people were
really positively receptive towards and
now you're doing this aftermath and of
course the thing that a lot of us are
anticipating that I hope we hope they do
right is the movie so I'm wondering if
they're trying to expand upon or get
people back invested more so into the
lore and storytelling departments of
mortal
that that way we'll be more excited for
when the movie comes out I really do
think they're factoring that in to how
they're producing these games and their
animated movies and such because I mean
look at it they're bringing all these
movie characters into Mortal Kombat so
I'm sure what they really have on there
and the fact that they got shanks on
from the original Mortal Kombat I know
this version the DLC version of the
forget that actor's name but having his
face on Shang Tsung has been around for
a while I do think that they want to
make sure people are gonna go check out
that movie - I think you know yeah and
that's I think they probably want to
separate themselves from that stigma
especially on the videogame side like if
I was making a video game and I was
aware of some of the limitations coming
to the big screen especially when it
comes to fighting based games like this
yeah I think that's actually a really
good point and I'm curious to hear more
of what people actually think about the
story of people are actually receptive
to that and are invested in it because
that is a really smart thing to do with
a movie on the horizon and you can bet
that the people who were involved with
the game are certainly involved with the
film even if they don't have like the
final say over the scripting or whatever
yeah so yeah and you know it would be
fascinating to get into the Wrights with
these because there's rights you smear
it around everywhere you know you got
Mortal Kombat having its own movie
rights kind of exported and then things
being imported into the games and
whatnot and now I feel like all we can
do is sit here and just come up with a
list of dream characters just throw it
these developers - uh yeah do our
ultimate nerd battles and I think also
too for aftermath to be focusing with
Shang Tsung as the main villain it's
great for all kinds of nostalgic
purposes not just going back to the
barrier like og videogames but of course
the Mortal Kombat 90s movie in and of
itself as well like I said I haven't
really been following the storyline The
Mortal Kombat the video game trajectory
like religiously in a while I only pick
up fragments here and there but I don't
recall the last time where Shang Tsung
was the main focal villain for all of
this he's a prominent character of
course but you know it's like he's
finally getting his - what was the quote
you said at the top I'll buy that for it
all of that is the quote
Hey I feel so vindicates coming back to
me now it's coming back to me now that
guy is always on the TV yeah right
you're right you're right we stayed to
this portion of the video John's right
real nerd for once in my life comes
around every once in a while guys what
do you think of this Mortal Kombat alone
aftermath trailer excited for Robocop
who else are you hoping they throw into
this videogame leave your thoughts down
below subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification but like you
check out my last of us to video last
but not least JT I'm shouting out JT in
this video specifically because our
Japanese man from Hawaii is definitely a
major gamer during this quarantine time
he has been catching up on some video
games that he genuinely loves and we've
been talking recently my dude and you've
been telling me how you want to catch up
on some certain writing ventures TV
shows and games as well and some books
so I just want to tell you dude that
after getting to know you for a long
time I think that you do have a really
gracious genuine heart and I would like
to see pursue more of your passions my
friend clearly you are an intellectual
type clearly you are a creative type and
I just wanted to go out there and
encourage you to you know carve out some
time a little bit every day to go pursue
some of your passions that you really
want to achieve in your life because I
know you're more than capable of it and
I believe in you my friend and I love
the hell out of you so I only want
what's best for you dude you're such a
sweet guy you should share that with the
world and I think you've got a lot of
great ideas that people would want to
hear and oftentimes it's the folks like
you who really need to speak up the most
so I'm looking forward to whatever comes
out of that brain of yours because I
it's ID a day whenever JT is around
where's your joke mm-hmm you usually
have a terrible joke to cap this off
with where's your bad joke you know I'm
giving up comedy after so many terrible
jokes I've just decided that it's really
not my forte I'm gonna now you give all
Mon that's right right now I'm giving up
on this joke and rj2 sincerity all the
way I was really setting him up there
but I'm sorry why did Captain Hook